لقب بالثعلب،
هو الرجل العبقري ذو ال١٠٠ وجه
، هو أول من صنع المتفجرات من المواد البسيطة للعمليات الاستشهادية،
وهو مهندس الموت الذي أرعب إسرائيل في حياته وبعد موته،
رجل عظيم خطط ودبر للعديد من العمليات التي هزت الكيان الصهيوني،
الرجل الذي طاردته دولة بأكملها، فأقلق مضاجعها،
وهدد أوكارها، رجل السعي والتخطيط،
(عن مهندس المقاومة الفلسطينية يحيى عياش نتحدث وللقصة بقية )
المهندس يحيى عبداللطيف عياش،
ولد قبل حرب نكسة ٦٧ بعام واحد،
كان هادئا متميزا في دراسته،
جعل من المحاليل والمواد الكيميائية معشوقة له،
وكان أحد أبرز قادة كتائب عز الدين القسام
في آواخر القرن العشرين، وبدأ عياش عمله العسكري عام ١٩٩٠،
عندما كانت المقاومة في أمس الحاجة لعقل مدبر ومهندس مثله،
حينها توصل إلى مخرج لمشكلة شح الإمكانات المتوفرة وندرة المواد المتفجرة،
وذلك بتصنيع هذه المواد من المواد الكيميائية الأولية
التي تتوفر بكثرة في الصيدليات ومحلات بيع الأدوية والمستحضرات الطبية.
فكانت العملية الأولى بتجهيز السيارة المفخخة في رامات افعال بتل أبيب،
وبدأت بعد ذلك المطاردة المتبادلة بين يحيى عياش ودولة الاحتلال
وأجهزتها الأمنية والعسكرية وبعد تحقيق شديد وقاس مع اعضاء في حماس
الذين اعتقلوا إثر العثور على سيارة مفخخة،
طبعت الشاباك اسم يحيى عبد اللطيف عياش في قائمة المطلوبين لديها للمرة الأولى...
وبعد ذلك بدأت قصة حب بين عياش والحافلات الإسرائيلية،
عندما بدأ هو بتصنيع عبوات خاصة بالحافلات،
حيث كانت البداية، بصنعه لعبوة تقدر ب٤٠ كغ من المواد المتفجرة
وربطها بجهاز تفجير و٤ أسطوانات غاز، لزيادة قوة تأثير الانفجار،
ثم استمر عياش بعمليات الحافلات، ودبر أيضا للعمليات النوعية الاستشهادية،
فكانت إسرائيل مستعدة أن تضحي بملايين الدولارات،
فقط مقابل رأس يحيى عياش، فمع كل عملية انتحارية استشهادية
يزداد الصهاينة غضبا وتزداد حملات مطاردتهم للمهندس،
( اغتيال مهندس الموت)
عندما زاد الضغط على الإسرائيليين وكثرت ضحاياهم،
طرقوا كل الأبواب الممكنة ليتخلصوا من المهندس،
فاستخدموا جيش الموساد ومعاونيهم من المستعربين لكنهم كانوا يفشلون مع كل عملية،
فالمهندس لا يستقر في مكان واحد وقتا طويلا،
إذ كان كثير التنقل، ولا يذهب إلى بيوت أقاربه لأنها ستكون مراقبة،
وأخيرا قرر الموساد استغلال أحد أصدقاء يحيى عياش،
فقد كان عياش يلجأ إلى صديقه كلما وجد صعوبة في التنقل وضاق عليه الخناق،
فطلب الموساد من صديق المهندس الذي صار عميلا لهم،
أن يجعل المهندس يستخدم هاتفا صنعوا متفجرات بداخله، ..
لكن هذه العملية طالت لأكثر من ٦ أشهر،
فقد راود المهندس الشك يوما بأنه مراقب وقام بتفكيك الهاتف ليتأكد،
وعندما لجأ إلى العميل في إحدى المرات، وأجرى اتصالا لكنه لم ينفجر،
فتم إعادة الهاتف إلى إسرائيل ووجدوا أن أحد الأسلاك كان مفصولا،
فأصلحوه وأعادوه مرة أخرى، وكانت العبوة التي المتفجرة بداخل الهاتف
ذات تحكم عن بعد من إحدى طائراتهم،
ويحكي هذا العميل أن عمله لم يكن سهلا بالمرة،
فقد شعر بالخوف بعد فشل المحاولة الأولى،،،
وفي ال٥ من يناير لعام ١٩٩٦، وكان المهندس حينها لم يبلغ ال٣٠ من عمره،
رُزق بطفل جديد، فأراد أن يبشر أباه وأمه، لكن خط  الهاتف الأرضي كان مقطوعا،
فاضطر لاستخدام ذلك الهاتف المحمول والملغوم من داخله،
وعندما تأكدت غرفة عمليات الاحتلال أن ذلك هو صوت المهندس،
ضغطوا على زر التفجير الموجود في طائرة تحوم فوق ذلك المكان،
وهناك قطعت رقبة المهندس وتهشم جانب وجهه الأيمن، وتم نقله للمستشفى،
وجاء كل قادة المقاومة ليطمأنوا عليه لكنه كان قد استشهد وفارق الحياة،،،
وبعد ذلك عم الإضراب مدينة القدس وضواحيها، وطبعت صور الشهيد المهندس
في كل مكان، وأقيمت له جنازة مهيبة بقرابة مائة ألف مشيع لجنازته في غزة..
رعب إسرائيل من المهندس لم ينتهي فقد تجدد في عام ٢٠٢١،
عندما سيطر الخوف على الإسرائيليين بعد موت عياش بربع قرن،
إذ أُطلق صاروخ اسمه عياش250، على مطار رامون،
وكان الخوف من اسم الصاروخ أكبر من الصاروخ نفسه،،،
عندما رأى يحيى عياش جنود الاحتلال في قريتهم، وهو لا يزال طفلا صغير
سأل والده، من هؤلاء؟ فقال له هؤلاء الذين أخذوا أرضنا،،
فقال عياش جملة غيرت حياته عندما كبر وهي
(هيا بنا لنذبحهم)..
والحقيقة أن عمر المهندس الصغير كان كافيا ليذيق الاحتلال أسوء هزائمهم،،،،
إذا أعجبك الفيديو، فلا تنس الضغط على زر اللايك والاشتراك بالقناة
وتفعيل الجرس لنستمر بالمزيد إن شاء الله..